another true crime story we probably
would never hear about if it weren't for
the movies white boy Rick the white boy
Rick is this true story about a kid
named Rick who is that's right he's
white Matthew McConaughey plays his
father they have a really [ __ ] up home
dynamic I broke their port that's
peddling guns most particularly ak-47
that's right a que 47 the very best
there is when you absolutely positively
have to kill every [ __ ] in the
room they have no substitutes so Rick
uses that game to get into this game and
then he creates his own game all the
while the FBI is like why don't you be
an informant really crazy like this kid
had it's one of those life is stranger
than fiction kind of moment what I liked
about the movies like I said it's an
interesting story
that's not to say anything about the
execution but the story's fascinating
also Matthew McConaughey Matthew
McConaughey is great he's just seens to
you everyone in the movie does a fine
job you can tell imagine McConaughey is
here everyone else is here maybe the
movie requires more of him but he just
shines more but really the movies pacing
is just off what I mean by that is the
movie could have been longer but if the
movie was longer the movie would have
felt too long so what to do you watch
this movie that just comes in shy of two
hours and it feels like you're watching
a movie that was intended to be at least
three maybe four which makes me walk out
of the movie with that feeling of it
would have been a better miniseries or
series make it like breaking bad but
with a teenage kid in the end you have
this movie that's a fascinating story
that's a choppy mess there is this one
scene where they're like all right you
need to go here and make contact with
this person set up this deal so we can
do this so we can bust these people in
the course of doing that you come in at
the tail end of all of it I was like
there's so much I miss there's a lot of
interesting [ __ ] that happened in there
that you just don't see any of that's
like popping on some porn and people are
laying there smoking cigarettes after
the fact parently I referenced 70s porn
you know what I'm saying though we
didn't come here to see what happened
after the interesting [ __ ] but to show
all that stuff would have made the movie
at least an hour longer which again
would have been a better series or
miniseries and you could tell they're
rushing it when he first meets these
guys like who are you we don't trust you
in fact we're friends now well he got in
there pretty fast I guess like nothing
in Rick's life lasted long enough for it
to be profound it felt like every big
scenario was a placeholder for the next
scenario which was a placeholder for the
next in that movies over you just feel
cheated there's some family drama with
the daughter
judging by
where the daughter ended up that's a
fascinating story in and of itself we
don't get that much of it I mean the
story of a kid who gets into crime gets
in with a gang and decides you know what
I'm gonna do this stuff myself that's
awesome for me to walk out of the movie
just feeling like I got the cliffnotes
that's depressing the premise itself
lends itself to tension why was there
not more tension in this movie this
movie just had to commit you want to
spend a lot of time on the setup you
want to spend a lot of time in the
aftermath you got to allocate
accordingly I didn't commit to how
they're gonna tell the story it's like
Miyagi said decide you're okay this side
you're okay in the middle just like
greatest movie just kind of got crushed
as it stayed in the middle safe in the
middle and doesn't stand out to anybody
like Picard when he didn't get stabbed
by the nos again at the dumb job table
guys in the end white boy Rick was just
a disappointment the premise is great
the trailer is awesome but in the end we
have a story that's deserving of a
better movie than it got I'll because
I'm not gonna remember this one at
t-minus one day yep I already forgot
sadly trailer is awesome Bryce a white
boy Rick have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
true story of crime your favorite crime
biopic whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you